hey guys I'm going to be promoting my
new podcast the way back here for the
next few weeks I'm very excited it's
going to drop every Thursday beginning
January 4th right here on my YouTube
channel you don't need to subscribe
anywhere else we'll work on getting it
out there wherever you get Podcast it
will be available but you can watch
video for sure right here on YouTube yes
I'm continuing the Honeydew it's just in
addition to that something fun something
a little different um going back to my
Ro in podcasting a little bit so I'm
excited for it um it's called the way
back and it's just a Nostalgia podcast
sitting back on that that uh station
wagon back seat the one that looked out
in traffic you know that's the one the
best seat in the house talking about
growing up and you know just laughing
and having some good times you're going
to get the way back on patreon also a
day early you're going to get it ad free
as well um I'm really excited for this
show I really M it got a great response
when we dropped that first teaser and uh
our first guest to kick off is Tom
sagora so it's going to be a great one
we've got a bunch of them in the can
already um you're going to see Mark
Norman Jim Gaffigan Joe list they're all
on there all right uh so make sure
you're already subscribed and uh here's
a little taste for
you I remember growing up we were
terrible kid my brother was a bit of a
pyro used take GI Joe's we would tape
bottle rockets we did the mailbox
baseball we're shooting BB guns Roman
Candle fights my mom didn't like anybody
she didn't even like her own kids these
are wire neighborhoods I didn't have a
curfew or a house how's all you go bro a
dog chasing us was a drag queen M noan
Ryan that fast ball boom right my
brother's
face yeah those were the
[Music]
days
the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
[Applause]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants Studios I am Ryan sickler
ryanr Ryan sickler on all your social
media and I'm going to start this
episode like I start them all y'all
thank you thank you for supporting the
show
whether you've been here or whether
you're new here thank you very much
subscribe to the YouTube it absolutely
helps the show all right continue to
support the special guys thank you very
much going to be promoting it forever I
learned that from uh Tyler the Creator
you promote at least for a year that's
what he said and that's what we're going
to do so you can also get that special
in audio form out there everywhere you
get your audio uh look and if you got to
have more of this show then you you got
to have the patreon that's what we're
here doing this this episode The patreon
is called the Honeydew with y'all and
it's this show with y'all and we
highlight the low lights with y'all and
as you're about to see y'all have some
of the wildest [__] stories I've ever
heard in my life and I love my job and I
love those of you out there who have
submitted and shared and bared your
souls uh if you are someone you know has
a story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydew podcast gmail.com
hopefully we'll get to do an episode
together all right now I want to make an
announcement right here on this episode
uh again the new podcast called the way
back it's going to be dropping every
Thursday on YouTube go subscribe now
we've got so many episodes banged this
guest here
included um it's going to be a new fun
show that I think you guys are going to
dig just a little trip down Memory Lane
uh with some fun guests all right and if
you're still looking for another podcast
to listen to go listen to my old podcast
to crab Feast that Library did over 1.1
million downloads in a year on a new RSS
feed that [__] Community is alive and
well so thank you feasters this guest
here today again you got to go hear his
episodes as well all right now that's
the biz come out for dates on the road
just go to Ryan sikler you'll see all of
them there all right now you know we're
doing here we're highlighting the low
lights I always like like to say these
are the stories behind the storytellers
uh today I'm very excited to have this
guest on uh what we're going to do today
though is is kick back a little bit
again like we do and take a break from
our trauma and show you a little bit
about what my patreon's all about and
some of our favorite moments ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Josh Wolf
what's going on josa listen you know I
cannot wait for the I was telling you
outside I cannot wait wait to see these
videos and I cannot wait to see your
reactions cuz we got some doozies for
you this time bro that's all they're
always so good you know my wife asked me
she was like is this that is this that
podcast you go on where you look at
gross stuff I'm like that's exactly what
it is yeah this is why she's like that's
why you fly down I'm like yeah I'm not
flying in just to see some normal ass
regular [__] no this is this is your
lane bro this is your lane you're the
guy and um before though before we get
started on on all these wonderful
stories please plug and promote
everything and anything Josh Wolf
comedian Josh wolf.com for tour dates um
oh coming up I'll be in Phoenix uh New
Year New Year's Eve at standup live and
um Adam Ray is doing that weekend with
me is he yeah all right so it's going to
be a really fun weekend so if you're in
Phoenix and you're looking for something
to do it's gonna be a good time also my
son Jacob will be there speaking of my
son Jacob we do a podcast called hey man
that's with three A's you can find we
decided to spell it the way I say it you
and so you can find it wherever you get
your podcast or subscribe to it on
YouTube it's a real fun podcast man and
he and I are having a really good time
we talk about just about everything um
from real serious kind of heavy
fatherson stuff to really he almost
talked me into buying a mini cow a
couple weeks ago wait I didn't even know
there were many cow neither did
I I was like yeah I want one of those
the max of mini Cal get it's still I
think around 4 or 500 lb oh okay it's
not like a [__] dude it's not a
little like your dog like a goat for a
cow as many and it starts pretty many
but then the and the poops anything
that's 500 lb like a calf size but it's
full like big yeah it's it's kind of
meaty you know it's a little meater than
a calf which I like but but they're cute
as [__] dude are they so Jacob was like
you should get anyi cow I was like let
me take a look at it and when I saw it I
was like I might have to have a many cow
are you kidding me right now that
[__] in Vegas that cow's going to be
hamburger and five
[__] it's going to just cook
out cook itself
out throw some cheese on me throw some
cheese on me I'm going to name that cow
slider yeah
okay oh well I'm very excited to have
you here for this episode that we like
to do it's nice it's nice to sit back
and not um boohoo about our [__] for
a little while and and share stories
from real people out there what's really
going on uh this is what's on the
patreon all right so I've started this I
don't know what we're on now a couple
years ago and the stories that come out
I always you hear me say it in the
introduction like oh like whatever I'm
telling you the the stuff we hear here
is unlike anything I've ever heard yeah
you know what else these shows always
make me feel better about my
100% dude I'm like oh I didn't wake up
under a bridge with missing limbs you
know what I mean yeah there that's right
that poor guy got run over by a train
yeah that's on the last episode he did
so I was like oh things are pretty good
you know I woke up all my digits all my
all my limbs everything after I leave
this show sometimes I take uh my
headphones off and I walk outside and I
take a deep breath and I'm like I'm
doing pretty good I'm doing pretty good
good
yeah yeah so let's get into it um first
clip here this is from episode uh 147
this is a kid called Craig conowal I
hope I'm pronounce your name properly
Craig uh Craig was a had to have a
double lung transplant okay so Craig's
born with cystic fibrosis okay and
basically what they tell him is this is
what you're dealing with and you're good
on these lungs till maybe your mid-40s
I'm I'm right around there and then
you're going to have to get a lung
transplant okay but he has to go in for
this medical procedure and they [__] his
lungs up and when he comes out of it
they're like remember that four
years you got you got to get it now and
you need a double lung transplant so now
he has to get in line that line is
forever and also he tells us that like
the tests to get someone's lungs into
your body it's like it was like8 hours a
day for a week okay so to get a match a
double lung transplant match is like one
in a billion it's a legit lotto ticket
he's in the
hospital and some lady through a friend
of a friend hears that he's in the
hospital and this woman says my son is
in the hospital and he's terminal and
he's passing why don't we just see if
their lungs are a match and then he gets
this phone call I get him I give him a
call and he goes Craig uh we got a young
man here who's passing away and his mom
knows about you knows you knows about
you and wants to give you the lungs I'm
like what [__] I'm like what do you mean
she wants to give me the lungs I'm like
no I have to be a match doesn't that
take like a while I'm not even on the
list yet he goes dude you're it's 100%
match get out here it's like one in a I
don't know man one in a couple million I
mean Jesus
Christ so
now he's got lungs instantly doesn't
have to wait in line he's got
lungs so they have a successful surgery
and then of course the parents of this
kid want to meet him they want to meet
the boy who their child's lungs saved
this kid's life yeah and he's torn he of
course wants to but also like I feel
guilty that I'm alive breathing and
talking to you with your son's lungs
yeah I can see that so he reluctantly
meets the the parents and everything and
as he's hanging out with the friends and
stuff they're like God you're you're
identical to him you're so much like him
you got to meet his girlfriend he's like
that's the person I don't want to meet I
don't want to meet his girlfriend
they're like you got to meet his
girlfriend and everyone keeps telling
her including the his donor's parents
like you got to meet her she's you got
to meet her so they meet and he
reluctantly meets her and then they
slowly start talking and they slowly
start hanging out okay
and then this
happens and um I pick her up at her best
friend's house we go for a ride and
we're on that bike for like six seven
hours like everywhere like we traveled
everywhere around the area we Brian we
must have did like I don't know like 70
80 miles that day on the bike non-stop
one day we're in her neighborhood We're
stopped at a a red bike they were on a
tandem bike and I just hear her go
they're on they're on a motorcycle
oh I
[Laughter]
I was like he got the lungs for that I
like these new lungs are really working
yeah got to break them in you know what
I'm just want a motorcycle get a lot of
wind coming down them first you
know they're new you know they're new to
him what a weird first date 70 miles on
a
t all right makes more sense so they're
on motorcycle and now they pull up to a
stop light okay and he hears her say oh
[__] we stopped at a a red light and I
just hear her go oh [__] and she just
goes like this and docks her head and my
dumbass goes like that and looks the
other way and it was my donor's parents
in their car and they know my motorcycle
bright red and his mom just is staring
as she goes by and and I'm not wearing
it home Deadlock just stared at me laser
laser beam and I just go oh what are we
going to do just I'm like maybe she
didn't know it was me maybe maybe she
just saw a motorcycle and she just
turned her head well I'm like let's pull
over we got to pull over we pull over I
donor's girlfriend's phone blowing up
blowing up and Sh was her she knows it
was us and she's not happy she's not
about it so so the parents didn't know
that they knew they had met or didn't
they encouraged them to meet and speak
and talk and they did but he reluctantly
was like I don't want to do I'm telling
you all I'm here meeting all of his
friends his family I don't want to do
that and they were like you need to you
should you should so he did they start
talking now they're starting to get a
little bit close and they're on this
motorcycle and they're riding around and
they pull up and he doesn't have a
[__] helmet on and that's a little
bit Cavalier if I'm going to be honest
you just got some brand new lungs you
ain't getting a new head you know what
I'm saying thr helmet on those lungs
okay you got new lungs yo the mom but
the mom boom you know what else strikes
me about that he said her parents and he
goes and the mom but he puts his hands
on the wheel so mom's driving mom's
driving dad and mom looks over and sees
slow turn
oh now now what okay they they've just
gone on a motorcycle ride up to this
point they've talked on the phone
extensively that's how it all started a
lot of phone talking and getting to know
one another and then hey we should do
this and he purposely picks her up at
her girlfriend's house because they live
in the same area and he's very concerned
about being spotted like this and then
it [__] happens okay so now check
this out this is what I love about this
show Craig you're born with cystic
fibrosis at at age 23 you have a
procedure where they [__] you up and now
3 years later way earlier than should
have been you have to have a double lung
transplant you find an identical donor
through a friend of a friend you you go
straight to [__] number one which
might be the first time in history
anyone's everever had double lung
transplant done this way and
then then you marry your donor's
girlfriend like a movie it really is
it's incredible you know it's it's
amazing how it all turned out but yeah
we're married listen to this and she's
um and she's pregnant with our with our
daughter we have a we have a daughter
doing may did they invite the mom to the
wedd I got to
know you got to at least send the invite
you know we'll follow
up what yo stole this dude's lungs and
his girlfriend bro and now it's his wife
and they're having a baby listen this
guy gets a a a lung lotto ticket and
[__] ends up marrying the donor's
girlfriend having a child together with
them and and it's it's we're his we're
making history on this pot we're
starting with history making episodes do
you think she ever said I know those
lungs are the same now let me see that
dick
yeah yeah I
do
oh man do you believe it wow that is fck
amazing is that a great that's a great
way to start listen it's a great way to
start what are the odds it's going down
over here going down what are the odds
like that there's so many crazy it's
like so many things need to line up to
get a double lung transplant done in
your body and he's like well what and
it's a like it's going to take years of
research to find this person they're
like nah this kid down the Hall
basically is is your match and his mom
kind of knows who you are and wants to
give you the lungs and his girlfriend
looks pretty good just in case he us
that's crazy that that is that is like
and you know why I love that story man
because I like to believe in things like
that when you think something can't
happen here it is here's your Miracle
but then you
then then to add on grabbing the girl
that is like and I think the mom driving
by is maybe one of the best movie scenes
of all time yeah for sure just that slow
drive for sure hard looking
right you know dude listen this is a
great episode his name was Craig Craig I
do want to talk to Craig about his
camera angle
too
yeah see we just need to lift that one
up for him just a little bit listen man
we give Craig a pass cuz this is this is
a Christmas episode y'all seeing what
happens uh that was a Christmas miracle
great Christmas miracle to start off
with now this is also I would say this
is also a miracle this one here too this
is she's one of my favorite um I've got
a lot of them but she's one of my
favorite guests we've had on here um
this is from uh episode
158 this young lady's named Aaron Cobb
Aaron Cobb was the unfortunate victim of
an attempted murder suicide in 2011 come
on uh the dude she was married to at the
time was um abusing the [__] out of her
stalking her and she wanted to get away
so she's over at her mom's house and
then he shows up at Mom's house and this
is what happens you know he starts
jawing and I just I'd heard it so many
times and my mom PE you know peeked her
head out the door she said Aon you need
to get inside I said Mom I'll be there
in one minute and he kept on and I
looked at him and I said we both deserve
a chance to be be
happy and he said something to me that I
can't remember and then he pulled a
Glock out of his waistband and shot me
twice and then shot himself in the
head okay this dude pulls a Glock out
shoots her and where do you know she's
about to tell us okay um and kills
himself okay you can go ahead and play
this next clip as soon as I saw started
to pull the gun I ducked I ducked so I
was like my top half is parallel to the
deck I have one bullet went in here
where my kateed artery is oh
no and the other went in through my
mouth and out through my jaw the bullet
that went through my karate because I
was kind of paralleled the deck it it
hit my lung and collapsed my lung and
then hit a vertebrae into my spinal cord
which paralyzed me you had one bullet go
down in your neck where your kateed
artery is and the other one went in your
mouth and out the back of your jaw yes
listen to me holy [__] you look amazing
you sound amazing I can't believe you're
honest to God I would I would never
[__] know good for you you're strong
as [__] you are thank you [__] this lady
get shot look at her can you tell no not
only that here's another thing I could
never tell
she's in a wheelchair I didn't I didn't
know
that I said look at you yeah you're fit
she goes well when you got to roll
around I was like a I didn't notice that
either I was about to ask did she start
this what's crazy the the guy shows up
pulls the gun out tries to kill her and
himself she obviously lives but the
thing is her mom's in the house so her
mom hears this her mom runs out past the
dead guy on the porch now her daughter's
been shot in the jugular and out the
face she's calling 911 and this [__]
lady lives and I mean she's got such a
good spirit she's got such a good
attitude about things uh I mean she
again she looks great facial like
there's no you could I mean you could
see when she pulled P but but the that
that reconstructive surgery let me ask
you a question if you're the mom you
move out of that house I mean be honest
with you do do do you put it forth on
the way back
from right I leave his body there too as
is buy
as you ever buy one as is
yeah but I can't right you can't no way
now I think she's beautiful okay and
here's what she told me she said that in
her in the world she's considered a
unicorn because she's a beautiful woman
in a wheelchair and there aren't many of
those and I said why is that and she's
like cuz mostly men do dumb [__] and I
just started laughing like yeah there's
way more men paralyzed cuz we're doing
ramp to ramp jumps and [__] Dragon
behind tractors and [__] although
although I will tell you this there's an
Instagram account called drunk people
doing things or something I is it 90%
dudes no but there's a lot of girls
dancing on tabletops where I'm like
you're one you're
you you're a vertebrae away on that one
for sure all right this next clip here
that's can I ask you let me ask you a
question about a lot of these people
that we've talked about there's got to
be some crazy inner strength and will to
live right I mean I not and then to come
on a [__] clowns goddamn podcast and
share it to the world like that it's and
I tell them before we record look
there's anything in here you don't think
you should say don't because sometimes
we clip these to show and we do the best
ofs and things like that so just be
careful with your story nobody knows it
no one knows what the [__] you're going
to say until you say it you know but
like when do they ever do you guys ever
get into that like where like with her
where did where did that will to be this
person and survive and have this
attitude where did that come from do
they tell you yeah what so what you can
subscribe and
hear next
one damn it I got to subscribe this gu
this is this listen to this story you're
about to hear again another crazy one
this is from episode 164 this is Matt
Burgess Matt Burgess college roommate
committed a triple homicide okay uh Matt
um the guy left their dorm and went to
his parents house okay um Matt only knew
him and lived them for two semesters and
everyone in the house is about to go on
spring break okay guy he's so he's a
roommate I only knew him for two
semesters I don't know him but he lives
here guy leaves to go to his parents
house okay so we all had that week in
February off and uh just out of nowhere
I got a text from one of my roommates
and he was one of his really good
friends and was like Hey Matt's parents
died in a fire last night and that was
all it said and I was like whoa so I
texted him back and I was like well is
he okay and the next text I got was they
think he did
it first of all I think I can speak for
both of us when I say I smoke too much
weed to think my roommate's a murderer
do you know what I'm saying well here's
the thing he did it yeah yeah he [__]
did it he did it this guy drove left
their dorm did he come back to the dorm
after drove to his family's house set
the place on fire killed him killed his
parent parents I think his sister might
have been I think he's he's [__]
killed him and
then where the murders happened where's
like two and a half hours away in Old
Orchard Beach he went there and did all
this and then he drove back to Oldtown
and went back to sleep at our our
apartment we were
renting what did he come home yeah he
went home he went sleep bro cuz he was
tired he worked hard went to sleep
y he was [__]
sleep oh my God he killed his not just
strangers yeah his family and drove two
and a half hours two and a half hours
that's on your F that's not on your mind
or it's on and then you go home just
knock out well dude he I mean I'm sure
he was tired you know he worked hard
this is proof Tom sagora you've said it
the sleep after a mass murder you got to
be it's got to be the best sleepest dude
ever
that's got to be the best Le you ever
had he probably was like listen so
relatively recently um Matt is told that
there's a podcast out there about this
murder okay the one that the guy that he
lived with committed and he goes to
listen to the episode and when he does
this is what he finds go ahead this is
what he finds out okay this is how far
after the murder and when where is the
guy um about 15 years and the guy is in
prison when he's being interviewed by a
psychologist okay so this guy's this
guy's been in jail yeah he's in prison
and this is years later and years later
this guy the murderer is now being
interviewed for this podcast and someone
tells Matt they heard this and they're
like this is your story so remember the
guy kills his family comes home and goes
to sleep comes home and goes to sleep in
his apartment in his home where he
is yeah done one interview and uh the
interviewer asked him all these
questions he was like no he says in the
interview that he's had a compulsion
since he was a kid to he's thought of a
way to kill every person that he's ever
met his entire life he said in that same
interview that the morning that he woke
up he was going to kill everybody in the
house but he slept in and we had all got
up and gone to work good of asleep it
was he killed those people definitely
had he overslept for murder bro he
overslept for mass murder that's how
good that sleep was this mass murderer
hit the snooze button could you imagine
finding out years later you were going
to be M brutally murdered slept in he
slept over slept can I just say this is
the he's the worst mass murderer of all
time me don't ask his family to them
he's the
best but you go home you and you don't
think you're a suspect or nothing you go
home and you just go to sleep sleep and
then you sleep through your next murder
like he's a bad he's not even good at
and the guy's planning the whole time
that two and a half hour drive back he's
like I'm wipe these [__] out
let me get some rest I'm tired yeah but
first let me get some
rest over sleeps for a mass
murder honey do with y'all y'all
highlight and the low lights with y'all
if y'all have a story that has to be
heard please submit the Honeydew podcast
gmail.com do you think he just came
downstairs with a knife and he was like
damn it
damn yeah for sure he looked at every oh
no that's the worst all no slept through
my mer SLE through my
murders oh my god dude do you think he
tells that story in jail I slept through
yeah I would have done more yeah I was
trying to kill six I got three to I got
real tired God now this one here this is
again this is a this is a this might be
one of my favorite episodes too having
to do with an elderly couple being held
hostage I still can't get through
somebody who slipped through a murder
dude I think about it all the time I
think about I'm not even involved with
that story I think about it all the time
like he planned to K I've overslept for
like getting my daughter to school you
know I mean I'm like oh my God he's
doing it for murder not just one murder
couple trying to kill everyone in the
house everyone in the house dude and
I've never even considered a human being
meeting me across from me and and
through their computer they're thinking
how could I kill this guy you know I'm
going to wait till morning every but he
said that guy said every person he met
he thought of a way to kill him every
person you make could you imagine that
sounds exhaust that lady when we were
out front today talking that lady that
pulled up to ask directions to the Tesla
place I gave her directions he'd be
looking at her like how can I kill this
[__] you know you know what's funny
every person when I when you were doing
that I was thinking to myself I wonder
if she thinks Ryan's going to kill her
because right she doesn't know us she
just walking up to the window
trustworthy we we were and we were and I
gave her good direction yeah the gray
hair makes us trust it does yeah um all
right so this is the next one uh this is
from episode 166 this is Seth Adams now
Seth Adams his great aunt and uncle in
their early 80s were held hostage for
hours all right so this is what happens
by 7 a.m. this guy that ends up taking
them hostage has already escaped from
prison and he's with an inmate and they
steal a car and they start driving it
and then he shoots the [__] guy he's
with and he sets the car on fire okay so
now people are aware at least the
authorities are that there's an two
Escape convicts they arrive at the car
they see that there's now only one
Escape convict and that guy couldn't
have gotten far he's probably locally in
the area okay well what he's actually
doing is watching Seth Adams great aunt
and uncle's house he's [__] case in
that place okay and they happen to be
heading to a morning doctor appointment
so while they're at the doctor
appointment he breaks into the house and
he takes all their guns in the house cuz
the old man has guns okay and then when
they come home he ambushes them and he
beats the uncle but he doesn't touch the
ant he's got the uncle tied up and then
Seth the guy telling the story one of
his other relatives is in law
enforcement and and knows them so he
calls the house to check on them say hey
this is going on in your air you guys
okay and then this is what
happens my uncles is the major uh I I
won't well it's knowledge but I don't
say who he is and he called and uh he's
not related to them but he knows I'm
really well and he's like uh and my aunt
I'm trying not to say her name my aunt
answered he let her answer but he had a
gun to her head and this is this is
funny but [__] up he she goes he goes
well where's soand so and my aunt says
he's a little tied up right now on the
fa I swear to god
dude she
she she's a Schwarzenegger line she
[__] dropped it in dude she did was
she sending a clue you think well yeah
so here's what happens next all right so
now he's got a the the criminal has a
plan to escape yeah but he needs the
elderly couple to assist him to do it
and here's his plan
okay well his plan is and this is when
they know they're going to die so he
says we're going to go to the bank
you're going to get all your money out
and let me take it I'm gonna bring you
back I'm gon go we're going to go get
gas then I'm gonna bring you back and
then I'll take the jeep with the gas and
leave well number one the bank's not
going to let them take all their money
out they they're they're retired they
have a bunch of money number two the
bank's going to be closed by the time
they get there which he may have not
known that but they did um so he wants
my uncle to drive the truck that's on
the side of the house he's going to be
in the back seat behind him wife in the
passenger seat gun to them gonna go to
the bank get gas go to the
bank all right that's the plan so the
uncle knows when they get to the bank
it's gonna be closed which that's GNA be
a wrap for him and his wife they know it
they also know even if it is open when
they go in and say give me all our money
they ain't giving them all their money
so now they're coming out with whatever
Max is and it ain't anywhere near all of
it and they are also going to be killed
for that so they know that this is it
they know this guy is going to hold a
gun to the uncle go get to the gas
station ant said no here's the thing
they said also if you listen to the
episode throughout he never [__] with
the ant something about her being female
I don't know if he related to her in
some way but he never he pistol whipped
he beat the [__] out of the uncle tied
him he [__] him up and a man in his
80s who's already injured going to the
doctor and stuff so he's going to hold
hold a gun go get gas we're going to go
to the bank the shit's going to go bad
at the bank and they know that's it so
they know if they get in this [__]
car with him it's [__] D and and
these these people are in their 80s and
how old's this dude that escaped do you
know but a healthy yeah he's a healthy
convict who's already killed he's
already killed this morning this morning
I don't know if they were buddies but
this morning lit him on fire shot him
and lit him on fire which seems Overkill
it's over it's literally Overkill really
probably just need to do one of those
yeah yeah yeah yo I got to tell you man
that do you when you listen to these do
you ever think about putting yourself
and how you would react in these
situations all the time and do you find
yourself I try to guess like where
they're going to go with the story I'm
like oh what's going to happen here a
lot of times I'm wrong were you right or
wrong on this one I was not right on
this one I didn't see this
coming see this coming can I throw can I
throw a guess in there yeah okay so I
because because she didn't [__] with the
he didn't [__] with the woman she's got
to be the one that initiates whatever's
about to go down so you know what
there's one gun he didn't get this is
what I'm saying there's a gun he didn't
get she gets it and that's the end of
this dude that's my guess all right all
right Uncle convin hey man you got my
wife at at the back porch you let me go
get the truck I'm not going to leave my
wife I'll go get the truck I'll drive
around back and then y'all can get in
guy says okay so they drive so my uncle
knows there's a 45 in the in the truck
my man the guy didn't get the 45 so
Uncle goes gets in the
truck pulls around to the back now he's
they said he was like fiveish feet from
this guy when this when it all ended
he's got the gun loaded everything opens
the door he yells at his wife run he
said she' ran faster than she's ever
seen R in her whole life just bed and he
pulls up shoots him the right nipple
bullet just goes in his chest and just
does a bunch of spinning around and just
doesn't come out the back and he said
the dude just went straight back gun
jammed after one shot though so if he
didn't kill him in one shot how about
that oh no yo first of all this dude's
Easter 80y old man had one hidden in the
[__] truck and said let me just pull
around and as soon as you said there was
a bunch of guns I was like he didn't get
all of them it wasn't a lady but it was
the old man dude I love that [__]
saved his wife saved him cuz they knew
they knew if we get in that truck it's a
wrap and he's like let me just go get it
pulled around have one hidden in there
and po I would love honestly just the
visual of an 80-year-old woman running
quickly yeah yeah
dude oh [__] everything's probably
popping and tearing her hand like I
don't no fear will make that body go boy
go but I'll tell you what after your
husband does that and you two been
through that I hoped they [__] like
rabbits yeah dude come on that
adrenaline that oh man I hope 80-year
old I hope they P went to pound town
with each other well I'll tell you what
she had a couple pull muscles running
they could have just been laying there I
mean this might be pound town for them
but whatever it is I hope you all got
some I hope you both got some yeah it's
more like still I don't know if there's
a lot of
pounding there's a lot of land how great
is that though that's a good that's
amazing y I bet you that dude was a
straight up hero in that town oh yeah he
hasn't he hasn't paid for a 400 p.m
dinner since you know what I'm saying
he's eating show he's for free for life
you know this dude gets free cornbread
at Perkins every time he walks in this
dude
Perkins they're like we still alive man
it's been 20 years Carl [__] die already
throw some ham on that plate
yeah dude I love this dudee
because yo that yeah I you know I love
the fact too because also at 80 what's
he got to lose right that's right what
do we got to lose man we're 80 we're go
we're already falling apart you know we
don't know what we got left but also
imagine living to 80 and then some [__]
like that comes at you [__] that man
yeah home boy was ready yeah dude and
stay ready got pistol whipped yeah he
took a a literal beating
he of the to to come up with this plan
he knew he had a gun in the truck yo
here's the other thing he could have hit
that gas and left his [__] like [__]
that
[__] she's your problem
now he could have yeah that's true he
could have he could have been just like
he was in love he loved her ass he's
like I'm swing around
here even if you hadn't had the
gun I might just drive right into it
yeah but he's holding her he's got her
on the P they're up on the porch oh oh
right right right so that's my mind it's
at least he can't run her over run him
over this is when he said run she just
bolted and he pulled up through the door
open and popped one through his titty
and the dude went back and thank God cuz
the gun jams and if he doesn't it's over
for both of them she ain't getting far
where she gone when he said she ran as
fast as she could I'm like dude she
honestly you know an 80-year-old that's
right an 80-year-old can Tri over a rug
that's how far their get off the ground
you know what I'm saying yeah wow wow I
can't tell you like these all have been
do with Y y'all crazy these are crazy
dude oh there we got plenty more here
the holiday season is here and whether
you're traveling back home doing gift
shopping hos the entire family or
recovering from the office holiday party
you've got to be staying hydrated no
matter where or how you're hydrating
this season liquid IV is the hydration
brand fueling your well-being and their
hydration multiplier can keep you going
through the end of the year and Beyond
now it's available in sugar-free choose
from three delicious flavors you got
white peach you got green grape and you
got lemon lime you know we love liquid
IV here we keep it here at the studio
for ourselves for all the guests it's
something I take out on the road it's
something I like to start my day with
they've been around with us for a while
we rock with liquid IV y'all we believe
in it with three times the electrolytes
of the leading sports drink plus eight
vitamins and nutrients for everyday
Wellness liquid IV hydrates two times
faster than water alone all in a single
stick grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar-free and bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20%
off when you go to liquid i.com and use
code honeydew a checkout that is 20% off
of anything you're ordering when you
shop better hydration today using promo
code honeydew at liquid
i.com you ever feel like money is just
flying out of your account and you have
no idea where it's going well I know
that feeling too man it's all those
subscriptions right think about it
between streaming services fitness apps
delivery services parenting apps it's
endless I'm guilty of it too so I use
rocket money to help me find out what
subscriptions I'm actually spending
money on and I had them cancel the ones
I didn't want anymore rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills I can see all of my
subscriptions in one place and if I see
something I don't want I can cancel it
with a tap I never have to get on the
phone with customer service and time is
valuable all right they'll even try to
get you a refund for the last couple
months of wasted money and negotiate to
lower your bills for you by up to 20%
all you have to do is take a picture of
your bill and Rocket money takes care of
the rest rocket money has over 5 million
users and has helped save its members an
average of $720 a year year with over
$500 million in canceled subscriptions
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
by going to Rocket
money.com honeydo that's rocket
money.com honeydo rocket
money.com honeydew now let's get back to
the de uh this is our boy Mike Frampton
Mike Frampton is a threee guest on here
Mike Frampton you've you've been
introduced to Mike Frampton before we
call him the death janit yes yeah mik
Frampton he did
a third part uh episode 170 this
particular episode is um now we do have
a photo that can accompany this one okay
so we just want you to see the photo
first
here so just in case you're new to the
show Mike Frampton's job used to be uh
we called him a death janitor he would
clean up murder scenes just Death Scenes
not necessarily murder you just someone
dies what ever cleaning up scenes
that's oh my you subscribe to the
patreon you're going to see that picture
we can't put that on YouTube oh now Mike
Frampton currently shifted gears left
cleaning up dead things to doing his own
Donuts got a dut business called
tragically dipped so if you're up in
Toronto area go get some donuts this
poor dude I love him he's like I'm
really going I went through so I was
like yeah you're looking this is your
job you're looking at this [__] every
day all day long the first one did
remember he did that guy who the gases
and the do the had gases like he's been
dead for weeks dripped on the lady
dripped on the body died and dripped on
this lady thought it was her ceiling
leak and it was touching
her it was touching like I want
new so that photo that you just all saw
there uh and if you're on the patreon
you actually saw it um was a result of
this right
here he was 24 years old and he showed
up at his girlfriend's parents house
where she was
living and they had decided they were
going to break up or she had decided
they were going to break up because he
was
cheating
and so he showed up at her parents house
with his
rifle and he stood on the front porch
and he knocked on the door and she
opened the door and he shot himself and
he killed himself when I got there the
dad was there but the mom wasn't and the
daughter wasn't so I was like okay at
police station right no the daughter's
in the hospital I said oh shock you know
I mean I just
traumatizing this kid's skull oh no blew
apart in a way that it made a triangle
piece that Rick Cade through the air and
cut her jugular no and she almost died
holy [__] holy [__]
no Happ dude no way dude shows up at his
girl's place they're going to break up
cuz he's shoot cheating excuse me shoots
himself blows his skull apart this poor
girl witnesses it and a piece of his
skull [__] goddamn uh throwing stars
right into her jugular and cuts her neck
and wait that's her no that's that's him
that's what's left of him yo but that
piece formed a triangle and [__] cut
her juggler and almost killed her yeah
have you ever have you ever in your life
heard of anything like that I wonder
it's the Honeydew with y'all y'all
subscribe today I wonder what the like
the odds of a piece of someone's skull
dud and the sharp hitting that exact
like and being a sharp piece that could
actually slice it y dude she could have
been standing an inch this way and been
okay yep gone right by her yo dude
that's a tough way to go that is a tough
way what happened to her well this is
kind of a long this one you might want
to sit
down I mean a she a a [__] G is crazy
like a baseball
diamond the [__] Throne star comes
out of his head slices are jugular bro I
bet you that's never happened before
that that could have never happened
before yeah it's it's wild because if
you listed like a 100 ways that you
might die somebody's shooting themselves
and yeah and their skull killing you is
probably down there on the list it ain't
even on my list I wouldn't even think
that's what I'm saying this is stories I
tell you I say it in the intro unlike
anything you've ever heard and I know
people are like whatever you know that's
fine I get get it I would be like that
too sometimes but I'm showing you proof
here that these are stories you're not
hearing anywhere else this is the
[__] best goddamn show on patreon all
right I'm putting my dick on the table
listen dude also it's your show it's
your show it makes you
like just walking outside Anything could
happen
anything a piece of skull could come
flying at you from down the street cuz
some dude [__] cheated on his
girlfriend now you're good
no okay well we're not done with Mike
Frampton so this next poor guy this guy
uh why does he still have that picture
which one the one but the he he so one
of the things we talked about I think on
the last episode is he collects or
actually it was on this episode he keeps
a momento of each thing something from
each scene he's got something from each
scene yeah yeah you know
like
uh because I've seen a lot of
movies the dude who keeps things from
murder scenes is
usually the dude who's doing the
murdering you know what I'm
saying I mean Mike I understand like I
don't understand n like so okay all
right well you know you know what I'm
saying if I was at a murder scene I
wouldn't be like wait let me get a
momenta let me get something I can't
remember if I asked him if he had the
skull piece or not but I know he keeps
momentos okay this next guy this poor
dude his wife just passed away and this
guy's just having a glass of wine in the
hot tub okay and unfortunately for him
he has a heart attack okay and dies but
he sits in that hot tub with it on for8
to nine weeks before he's found okay uh
a roofing crew shows up to do some work
on the house and this is what
happens and he just sat there and the
tub ran until the water level hit
something I guess and shut the pumps off
so it doesn't blow the Jets out and so
when we got there everything was shut
off and it was just like a big giant hot
tub full of brown soup and so the corner
went out and they would have grabbed the
bones out of the soup but all the
muscles gone when we stirred it up a
little bit there was there was full
hands like the glove the skin the skin
all the skin de gloved off of
everything there was just peeled off
bro a skin suit like
[Music]
legit what the
[__] so everything slipped out of the
skin yeah broke up yeah just like a rib
just slid off like a rib just slid off
like a rib bro it did like
body oh my God and then you I love what
he gave a vision of like stirred it up
like you had a giant spoon but you hear
how he talks about it like it's nothing
like it's nothing that was his job oh my
God brown suit wait they're not done
they got to clean the mess up what for
they got to clean that up you can't just
leave the scene cuz it's a house
somebody's house now it's that your
house you ain't lying I like we're out
here I'd be like you know what I bet you
they'd hire in the next County over I'll
tell you what this be you'd be the guy
that shows up to do this I would be the
same way so they hire the septic truck
okay they hire a septic company and they
they don't know what the [__] do so
like bring that septic truck out we'll
suck up all this soup um and then the
guy gets there and the guy's like I
ain't [__] doing that the septic
dude's like you can do it and shows them
yeah how to [__] use it yeah so the
they set it up and then um the
construction workers or his excuse me
Mike's partner says fire up the
Jets oh oh no no no no no oh no no no no
no no no I know exactly and then my
partner said go and turn the power on so
we can start cycling the Jets out well
the power kicked off because the Jets
ran like hot or whatever and so when I I
was like are you sure he goes yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I hit this power breaker
and I heard the Jets fire up but I can't
see the hot tub and I hear him gagging
and screaming and what happened was we
turned the [__] hot tub back on so he
got sprayed by like 40 Jets full of
decom 40 Chets of De Head To Toe to Toe
covered in covered in it and like this
doesn't smell
good you know what it went in his
[__] eyes it went in his
mouth dagging and throwing up he's
getting angry
like he said he's getting angry no [__]
is getting angry getting i' have been
[__] right at to get i' have been on
the get from the Geto [__] I
wouldn't be it wouldn't be building up
I'd be like hey I'm angry
now yo man when did you get angry when
this [__] started that's what holy [__]
D yo yo yo so he's covered in this other
dude's insides yeah dude I might head to
toe bro in his mouth in his eyes see
here's the deal I don't know if I ever
recover from that do you know what I
mean you don't qu he's doing
D tragically thck yo if I'm that dude I
probably move to the top of a mountain
somewhere and just like how do you ever
get that off you ever ever there ain't
enough lofas on this Earth to scrub that
[__] off I would actually I might need
that dude's skin from theot dry yeah I
might dry it out and take mine off you
know what I
mean you know by the way that sounds
like an origin story that's how a super
villain is created you know
dude cuz brown soup that means there's
organs and stuff oh everything was in
there everything it just it cooked them
it it like a human soup like they threw
him in as the ingredient and he just
heart attack right away and then that
hot water just cooked them for days and
days until it ran low enough below the
Jets where then the Jets overheat and
shut off so they soup you know they find
whatever's left in this [__] thing
then they suction and cup it out and
then that jackass says let's power up
the Jets and clean thing out and but you
know what he is the one who said power
up the Jets do you know what I mean he
is the one that said power if if he said
power up the Jets and I was the one who
got sprayed he we'd be fighting we I
would get fired from my job yeah and I
would rub it all over all over D do you
know what I'm saying yeah I would tackle
you I'd be chasing you in that yard dude
yeah dude it would be me and you in this
together brother you know what I mean
for sure yeah oh God I think I think
it's worth noting that Mike didn't keep
a momento from that story but his
partner did yeah it's a great Point his
partner who got covered like that that's
right I was wondering which one this was
if it was the next one or this one but
his partner kept the hot tub the whole
hot tub kept the hot tub wait you ready
you should make you watch the episode
for this but I'm going to give it to you
kept the hot tub cleaned it all out
threw a hot tub party and waited till
everybody was in the hot tub and then
told him where he got [__]
waited dude would you be pissed I'd be
pissed D I'm like what what I I'll be
getting out of there oh dude yo you
can't do that to somebody that's the hot
tub that had the man soup in it oh [__]
you we found a dead guy in this and we
cleaned it out and this why I got it
haha is and I'm a guy who likes pranks
but that yo if you do that to somebody
you have to expect to get punched in the
face yeah more more than that all right
we're going to move on to this next one
now this is I thought you were going to
be like he kept a bone or do you know
what I mean like a a bone I think that'd
be illegal actually highly illegal a
human bone at your house is going to
raise some
suspicions try telling the [__] uh
police it's a souvenir good luck with
that [__] you're going to jail as soon
as you say that yeah you're probably
right no no he called a souvenir we
don't even need to prosecute this
[__] he's a Serial K whole
yard's probably got bones in
yeah you're probably right you're
probably right maybe maybe a hand glove
maybe just a this next guy here uh this
is episode 154 this is a gentleman named
Cody stradley now Cody Cody stradley
also did biohazard cleanup okay um and
now he's dealing with this one in
particular is a dementia is a lady with
dementia who's clogging her sinks and
her toilets okay and this is what
happens I don't know how long man but I
would say for a [__] month
this lady is using her
bathtub as the toilet so there's a
[__] six inches of piss and [__] and
toilet paper in this [__] bathtub so
that's what this lady's doing collecting
her piss and [__] in a bathtub she's a
hoarder she's hoarded herself into the
corner and now she's got nowhere to run
and nowhere to hide listen dude there
was a guy that I knew in college that he
he was just like well when I I don't you
know I don't want to have to run to the
bathroom when I'm in the shower so he
was like I just [__] and I shove it down
the drain with my feet no e he matches
it with
his oh God for
[__] yeah that is filthy I will tell
you it didn't go very well they yo they
came back and the like the whole it was
a suite right it was just flooded with
you're not supposed to [__] in the tub
everybody you know what I'm saying
that's one of the deals that's why you
that's why they have a toilet or they
would just have a tub and so but they it
flooded over yo this is the same dude he
was on the football team and um he ran
up to fart in somebody's locker and it
wasn't a fart it was a [__] and he
[__] sprayed [__] all over this
dude's shoulder pads and thigh pads and
his helmet his entire and he was like my
bad he was an offensive lineman so what
you going to say him but this dude had
some definite [__] problems but [__]
in a tub and stomping down it I've never
in my life heard of that yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's you know why you haven't heard
of it cuz you're not supposed to do
it why it's not a thing that's right
that's right not even on Tik Tok um so
that's what's going on so now here's
what they have to do to handle this
situation okay it's the [__] Eerie
part it didn't smell when I first walked
in we started sucking up and we broke
that [__] film that's on top and dude
I'm [__] telling you I
cannot look
at know why she put four hot dogs in the
bathtub you sure she wasn't
[__] you sure she was [__] those I
don't [__] know what the [__] was
going on man they had
them they were in the sink they were in
the bathtub four [__] hot dogs look
at him he's
gagging he's gagging and he did
it would you like a hot dog yeah I'll
eat one I wonder if she y I wonder if
she was just like you know what might
taste
good you want my cook this hot
dog full [__] hot dogs in the [__]
bro and the [__] s here let me tell you
something oh God disgusting that that
has to
be it's so sick full hot water are they
in there why you know
what maybe she was just like that's a
good hot
dog maybe she was trying to kill the
smell and she was like you know what
might kill this smell you think these
kill the smell of that no dude I don't
think so cuz they don't yeah but trying
to make sense to somebody who was
[__] in the tub you know what I mean
there's got to
be cuz isn't there a time doesn't she
break the seal every time she shits in
the tub oh God I got to put my hot dog
down do you know what I mean every every
time she I didn't think of that I
guess I guess there's a film over it
every time and every time she drops on
it it breaks or pisses and it breaks oh
oh God I I'm with you though my My Hope
Is that she brought those hot dogs
swallowed the hot dog hole and [__] it
[__] it out hole listen I have certainly
in back in my drinking days in college
and [__] eating a 7-Eleven big bite it
was in there for hours and then I would
throw up and it would come out in two
pieces you know what I mean and it
looked like you could literally pick it
up and eat it again I don't know if that
happens out of your [__] I don't know
goes through some things yeah dude you
know what I mean does just sit here and
come right back up I I you know what
though but that that it's trying to make
sense of somebody who was [__] hot
tub so the hot dogs actually kind of
make sense do you know what I mean
because you and I you and I aren't like
you know what this [__] tub needs is
eight kill
bosses you know what I mean that's not
that's not a thing yeah I all right
we're gonna we're gonna move on does he
have a souvenir from that this guy's got
a wild story as well the Honeydew with
y'all y'all if you got a story that has
to be heard please submit it to honeydew
podcast to Gmail
best show on patreon best money you're
going to spend I promise you that all
right this next guy uh again another
crazy story we're past a lot of the
gross stuff if that's not up your alley
hey we're past it um kind of episode 163
this is Tyler farum Tyler farum is a
skydiving instructor who's bringing his
mom for her first jump okay ever and
he's going along with her and on the way
down
Tyler his parachute gets
Tangled the last thing I remember I was
spinning I was spinning completely
sideways and the last thought I had was
I think I'm G to die this this must be
it and then everything just went
black and as soon as I lost
Consciousness which I think it's from
that Cent centrifugal force but then
also just fright you know what I mean so
like losing
Consciousness I landed in the field
right right next to the runway about I'd
say about 6 feet from the paved Runway I
landed in the grass and I caused it
indentation in the earth dude hits so
hard his body caused a dent in the earth
well he jumped out of a [__] plane
right yeah yeah but the shoot was out a
little bit it was slowing him but it
tangled so it wasn't stopping him he was
still Hur where was his mom his mom a
great question cuz we're about to see
but his mom was about to jump so she's
literally in the air above watching her
son plet Rob Stevenson he was the first
one to respond over to me because he saw
what was going on saw this commotion and
he said I resembled a ragd doll he's
like your legs arms everything poin in
different directions and he knew he had
some first aid knowledge so he's like
first thing we need to do is get an
airway so I had a full face helmet on so
he had to take the take the helmet off
blood coming from my eyes nose
mouth
Yeah man so like I I was choking on my
teeth because I I knocked out nine
teeth
okay here's the thing bro choking on
your own teeth after you [__] hit the
earth okay out of a plane bro and here's
the thing his mom is a nurse okay his
mom also has a bunch of her nurse
friends who've come to watch her make
her first jump and he said his mom
always told him that a nurse has a look
on their face when things aren't good
they they're very good stoic to keep
together but he said you can tell that
this nurse is like so his mom is now
she's floating slowly floating down and
there's this whole commotion on the
ground she doesn't know it's her son and
as she's floating down she looks over at
her group of nurses and she said they
all had that nurse face like some [__]
and that's when she was like oh [__]
that's my kid and so his mom watches him
plummet to the Earth and and Dent the
Earth [__] bleed from the eyes choke
on teeth and look at him he lived he
[__] lived so so what H okay you
gotta find you got to join the patreon
oh yeah yeah yeah I got a bunch of
questions dude yeah like all of them are
answered in the patreon Subscribe today
what so was he conscious like and and
can remember being on the ground and
having that dude over him no he said he
said the last thing I remember he's
being told this this I came over I did
this I took your helmet off you were
bleeding from the guys well I think they
metac them out of there like that dude
arms and legs were in all different
directions and again looks [__] great
wheelchair no no he's not in a
wheelchair let me ask you a question
you're when you're doing that mhm and
this is I mean I know most people's
spinning like this this is what I'm I
think I would want to pass out yeah I
would throw you would have to right like
you know that lady in that [__] metal
you've seen that like there's no way
that woman was conscious there's no way
and here's the thing like first of all
I'm for sure [__] myself I'm for
sure the whole bowels everything's going
and I want to be unconscious because I
also think limp you have a better chance
of surviving than tense like this and do
you know what I mean and if I hit the
ground I think I'm going to be tense
you're defin if you're awake the whole
time going down like you're definitely
going to tense up and then shatter like
glass oh dude that crazy yeah and your
mom's coming to watch and
SE dude now this one this next one go
ahead you have you have something to
say yeah like what is this dude well
I'll join the patre join the pat
J uh episode 142 now this is Tyler Kelly
this young man was unfortunately in a
work accident that left over half his
body with second third fourth and fifth
which I didn't even know there were
degree burns they're clean so what he
what happened isn't that just
dust it might be he sneezes in his
forearms
gone yeah that
seems [__] head Falls ground like God
damn all right this poor guy his job
he's he's cleaning ash from the Ducks of
a coal burning plant okay and some [__]
goes wrong and this is what happens he
goes in to do that there's an explosion
and this is what
happens so you do have all your fingers
look at his hands but you're pinky on
this side see the skin coloration
fingers are ja
fingers all right so he gets burned like
that now and the burns are on his hands
well they're he's got Burns everywhere
on his body but he's showing us what he
can okay basically now here's what
happened hard Hat's gone all I have is
my respirator I thought what with what
my gloves were was actually when my AR
when I stepped outside and my arms hit
that cold air they just just swelled up
and slid off the glov like snake skin no
no no no my skin skin oh my God I had
three three foot SE in of my that's why
my that's why my fingers are drawled up
like that listen I have a lot of because
the skin has the fingernails held the
skin on oh they just holding the skin on
bro the fingernails are holding it down
this oh my
God holding the skin on thank God for
fingernails I'm never going to bite mine
again I tell you something I always
wonder what they were for but it's there
they're there to keep your skin on I
guess I'm always like what are these for
they keep your skin on keep your skin on
dude yeah the toenails and the
fingernails keep the whole thing
together I had no idea dude that's a
work accident that burned him like that
but bad and his buddy's in there so
she's trying to help him to and they're
stuck in this duck just getting torched
so now he's at the hospital and and as I
know as well in order to leave they want
him to pee okay but he can't so the same
thing they did to me they threaten
shoving a Cather in your dick hole why
do why do they need him to pee why they
need to make sure you're you're
functioning properly before they release
you you need to be able to pee on your
own and if you can't they stick a
[__] catheter in you nope and he's
that same thing so he's the same way
he's like [__] that I'm not taking a
catheter and all he wants is he says if
someone just if there's just some air on
my dick if someone just blows on my dick
I I'll pee and so he asked the nurse to
do it and the nurse got pissed
off he got
mad wellit doesn't he have like a friend
or something you got well he's got a
couple people in there okay and I asked
my mom that was just weird to ask your
mother to blow on your dick but my
sister volunteered she's a
trooper she's a trooper she
volunteered she is so when she blew all
my dick they couldn't get the the urinal
in in front of it fast enough so I
pissed all over her face so that
probably might that might be the only
golden shower she'll ever get in her
life was from her own
brother have you ever heard anything
that in your life bro I'm telling you
what are you waiting for subscribe by
the way I I hope you got her a good
Christmas
present he said that might be the only
golden shower she ever gets or her
brother Jesus Christ or maybe she likes
it now you know maybe she's like you
know I didn't hate
that yo dude how do you repay your
sister for that like I mean I don't know
if you
can how else can I ask you another
question is it common knowledge that if
someone blows on you dick you have to
pee I mean is it just air he knew though
he knew I told him I know what it feels
like I remember hiking and just having
to piss and going over by a big tree and
H cuz I'm very paranoid about getting um
like someone saying you're a sexual
pervert jerking it or something when I'm
just taking a and when that wind hits
really oh you've never next time there's
a good Breeze and you're somewhere safe
whip it out and take a leag and that
that wind dancing on your dick and balls
is magical well I think that's probably
true also but I if it would make I don't
have a sister
so and my mom
done wait wait the dude asked his mom
listen do you have a good relationship
with your mom yeah not could right would
you ever I'm picking sister volunteered
he didn't ask her she's like I'll do it
like what yeah yeah yeah he said she's a
trooper yo I I first of
all I if I'm
her I'm going to I'm I'm gonna need some
retri I'm gonna need some payback I'm
gonna need something you have to do
something for me you peed all over my
face which means probably into my mouth
too probably and eyes it's always in the
eyes too probably for
sure well you know either by the way
either that made them way tighter or
they don't talk
anymore what happened between you guys
it's a long subscribe to the patreon you
he this is so crazy all right this we
got two more we got two two more here
all right this next guy Austin Thorne
now Austin Thorne is from episode 152
all right Austin Thorne shot his home he
ALS okay first of all you got to watch
the rest of the episode to see this he
had a serial killer ant okay that's just
one of the stories but the other story
is that he shot his own eye out um and
here's what happens uh to shooting his
own eye out I Put on Full Auto on my
paintball gun and start blasting it away
and as I release the trigger it keeps
shooting for another 3 or 4 seconds
that's it's a big issue so I decided
okay well I'm going to try and fix this
so I am to you the hopper which carries
all the paintballs and then I shot
once and then immediately turned the gun
around but rather than being smart and
turning it around so that I could just
see the gun like this I turned the gun
around so the barrel was facing towards
me so I pulled the trigger immediately
turned it and as it was turning
apparently a paintball didn't come out
of the hopper or something there was
still one in there and it just went off
again immediately as it crossed crossed
in front of my eye and I I didn't know
this at the time but it blew it up into
six pieces and my retina was out there
on the ground somewhere you ever heard
the sentence my retina was out there on
the ground
somewhere you that sounds like you can
on the Honeydew with y'all y'all have
you ever no it sounds like a nerv lyric
that is crazy are you are you kidding me
right was on the ground yeah that out
there somewhere yo so okay okay okay so
what happens then what's left just a
hole in his head oh that's a great
question why don't we finish watching
he'll show us he show us man this thing
has been was he going to take it out wow
the abuse
this this is what he does with his eyes
oh yeah I've thrown this thing as hard
as I can at my co-workers holy [__] oh
I'm a little [__] with it I how heavy is
it is it like a marble weight like what
sort of weight is it for our
ey yeah I'd say probably like a marble
like is it like a paintball
pellet uh no thank you
thank no thank you come back come back
wa yeah no
it's godam look at him d f he throws
that at
people yeah easy he throws it at people
look at him putting it in it's all
fleshy back there look at it e you're in
the contact see can I tell you something
yeah okay at my shows every now and then
I'll bring somebody on stage uhhuh and
if it's a late show and I'm taking
mushrooms I do I do this thing called
the dance off where I'll have cple
people on stage and I have my guitar and
then I make them do interpretive dance
behind me in the wi gets
$100 well one girl one woman gets on
stage and I said tell me the name of
your best dance move and she said the
Cyclops and I was like huh I
wonder and I said to her friends I go
have you all seen this dance and they
were like oh yeah and I said am I am I
gonna like it and they were like we
think you're gonna like it so she
started dancing and then she just
[__] popped her eyeball out and
started doing like this in front of my
face and I was like nope
[__] NOP
because I was surprised just like that
one I thought they were all like Bond
villain eyes like eyes yes like an eye
but they're not what the [__] is that
that's a picture he said so you can see
you wanted to know what it looked
like there it is bro yo if I ever get
pulled over by the cops that's what they
would see when they walked up to the
window this is why I'm what do you mean
why am I driving erratic this is why I
can't yeah I'm having a hard time seeing
this part of the Road God that is the
best picture except the left eye part
but everything else yo because look at
it get in there
Kirsten yeah yo
dude he I mean I guess he would have to
[__] with people right what do you think
we would do if we had a [__] one eye we
would do that dumb [__] I would
absolutely throw it at some for sure I
would put it on my finger and be like
let me take a look at that you know what
I mean I would do [__] like that you got
something in your
let me see behind your head for a second
oh yeah yeah yeah that's a yo all right
we have one more to go here guys this
has been a lot of fun uh thank you for
doing this we're not done yet we're
going to go out on a fun little one here
a little
lighter upbeat one um upbeat a little
bit I feel for this show it's upbeat
it's I mean it's not but you know if
you're on this show [__] ain't going
good you know what I'm uh
but so here we go this is from episode
144 this is Kenneth travan all right
Kenneth had a brain tumor that grew
undiagnosed for years all right and he
his head his feet and his height he
grows two inches he's he's a full grown
man yeah all growing his head his feet
so I'm like did your dick grow he's like
no it's the only goddamn thing that
didn't grow that's what happened to Tony
Robbins what he had that tumor uhhuh he
had a tumor pressed up against whatever
that gland was that made him Ma giant is
that right I didn't know that yeah yeah
yeah he grew he went from 510 to 6 foot
this guy his feet got bigger his head
got bigger everything no [__] there is a
particular hormone that came back uh
it's called prolactin which if you know
what that is it's the it's the hormone
that when females get pregnant it's what
makes the milk in their in their breasts
hell yeah guys have it as well we just
don't have a lot of it right right so
our level is supposed to be between
somewhere between two and 17 that's what
the level in your body is supposed to be
when my blood panel comes back I was
just shy of 1600 one part I guess I
didn't bring up is at the time that they
found it my daughter is going to kill me
but at the time that we found it my
daughter's starting to kind of go
through her puberty stage so she's going
through like hey man why does my shirt
why is my shirt hurting you know my when
I wear my shirt why is it hurting my
chest is that
I'm having the same exact thing I'm like
yeah why is my shirt hurting while I'm
wearing my chest that's one of the
things that brings it on it's like you
start developing like female you start
you you you and your daughter grew
titties
together titties together did you guys
go bra shopping together guy titties
with his daughter I feel like I'm about
to do the same with my
daughter what a great bonding experience
poor bastard out of brain T GRE with his
daughter wait did milk come out of him
no he didn't get the milk well no he
didn't get the milk because he said
that's what generates the milk yeah
that's what generates the milk oh [__]
he grew titties with his daughter what
size got to watch the P you you can't
was he a healthy beac cup did he come
through does he still have him did he
come through for
who come
through
he's counting on his titties right now I
am for [__] sakes to tell you the
truth I want to see what's his name his
name is D oh sorry Kenneth travan yo
Kenneth did he show you his titties you
gotta wash the oh my
God he's better now thank god oh that
his titties went away well I I think so
it didn't look like he had titties there
no it didn't listen that is it uh before
we wrap up though I do want to say uh I
want to give a special uh shout out to
unfortunately we had a guest who um he
came and he did an episode and he passed
away and I want to give him some love
his name's uh Daniel porier I I hope I
pronounced that correctly and his
episode was 149 all right he had at the
time he spoke with me he had an
inoperable stomach tumor um and he
passed a couple months ago and his wife
had reached out and said hey could I get
that episode so we sent that to her as
well and um I just want to say thank you
I mean that's we get people like that on
coming on and they're passing away or
they're they're going through something
right now and they may not be here in a
few months so again thank every single
one of you out there who have done the
show thank every single one of you who
have subscribed to the show thank all of
you out there for all your support on
all of my stuff my podcasts my new
podcast the way back my special the
album we're on Spotify video now all of
it thank you so much none of this will
be possible without you guys please
subscribe to the patreon have a great
holiday thank you Josh Wolf for coming
back on can say whatever you want listen
this is why there are there's nobody
else who could do this show what you've
always been great at even with like
especially with with this podcast is
giving people a play people say [__] to
you that they don't say to other people
I yeah they do and you are a great
combination of understanding but also
and um and great at listening but also
look man it's not easy to interject
comedy in the topics in the subjects
that you and you're an expert at it by
doing it in a in a fun non-offensive way
to the people who are bearing their
souls to you dude there's very few
people who could do what you do it's so
fascinating to watch awesome I do
appreciate it that's awesome um and I
love you and I support all that you do
so please promote plug it all comedian
Josh wolf.com for tour dates everybody
um New Year's Eve we're in Phoenix uh me
and Jacob and Adam Ray and then uh tour
I'll be out and about everywhere but
take take a listen to the podcast that I
do with Jacob it's called hey man it's
really maybe my favorite thing I've ever
done I feel so lucky right now to be
able
to combine work with my family it's
really been the best time of my life and
on being on the road with him man is
really like I love that you've been able
to do that I love that you've done that
best thing I've ever done best thing I
love it I'm proud of you thank you so
much for having me dude these are always
my favorite dude you're always our
favorite to do this it's always fun uh
and as always Ryan sickler on all social
media Ryan sickler
[Music]
[Applause]
n